en 1931 paraissait dans la revue monatte
chef furent mathématiques un article au
titre apparemment incompréhensible écrit
par un jeune logicien qui n'avait
seulement que 25 ans courte gaudeul cet
article contenait deux théorème qui
allait révolutionner notre compréhension
du fondement des mathématiques les
théorème d'incomplétude
[Musique]
la première fois que j'ai entendu parler
du premier théorème d'incomplétude de
gödel c'était en cours de philo en
terminale
notre offre nous avait expliqué que ce
théorème affirmait qu'en mathématiques
il existerait toujours des vérités qui
sont indémontrable je vous avoue que sur
le coup ça m'avait un peu choqué 1
qu'est ce que ça veut dire exactement
qu'il existe des choses qui sont vraies
mais indémontrable et comment affirmer
ça ça peut être un théorème
eh ben on va essayer de le comprendre
ensemble en mathématiques on passe son
temps à faire des démonstrations et
d'ailleurs c'est assez fréquent que les
exos de maths qu'on fait au lycée ou
bien plus tard soit posée sous cette
forme par exemple démontré mois que la
somme des angles d'un triangle fait 180
degrés ou bien démontré mois le théorème
de pythagore ou démontrez moi que racine
de 2 peut pas s'écrire comme une
fraction et c'est l'idée qui traîne
derrière c'est que si on arrive à
démontrer quelque chose c'est que
quelque chose doit être vrai par exemple
le théorème de pythagore bas on sait le
démontrer et il est vrai il fonctionne
il n'y a pas un seul triangle rectangle
dans lequel il marcherait pas c'est ça
l'intérêt de faire des démonstrations
c'est pour être certain que quelque
chose est vraie inversement si quelque
chose est vraie on se dit qu'il doit
être démontrable ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on a déjà trouvé la démonstration
mais on est sûr qu'il doit en exister
une quelque part donc quand on fait des
mathématiques à notre niveau
vrai et démontrable on fait comme si
c'était la même chose ce qui est vrai
est démontrable ce qui est démontrable
est vrai et bien pour comprendre l'objet
des travaux de gödel il faut commencer
par réaliser que non vrai et démontrable
ça n'aide pas la même chose pour ça il
faut commencer par se demander qu'est ce
que c'est une démonstration
alors c'est pas toujours explicite quand
on fait des raisonnement mathématique
mais les démonstrations en maths utilise
qu'on appelle la méthode axiomatique
quand on fait des raisonnement
mathématique au départ on se donne un
nombre restreint d'affirmations que l'on
va admettre sans démonstration on
appelle ça les axiomes et dans une
démonstration on combine ces axiomes en
utilisant les règles de la logique dans
le but de créer de nouvelles
affirmations et ses nouvelles
affirmations on les appelle des
théorèmes alors on va commencer par
prendre un exemple simpliste imaginons
que je me donne trois axiomes axiome un
tous les êtres humains sont mortelles
axiome de tous les hommes sont des êtres
humains et axiom 3 socrates est un homme
alors vous voyez qu'en combinant les
axiomes 1 et 2 et en appliquant les
règles de la logique je peux déduire
l'affirmation suivante tous les hommes
sont mortels
cette affirmation c'est un théorème
c'est à dire qu'on l'a déduite des
axiomes
on a fait une démonstration mais
maintenant en combinant ce théorème avec
l'action 3 je peux déduire un nouveau
théorème qui dit socrate est mortelle
alors cet exemple est ultra basique donc
on peut pas aller beaucoup plus loin
mais vous voyez l'idée on part d'axiome
ont construit des théorèmes et on peut
s'appuyer sur ses théorèmes pour
construire encore de nouveau théorème et
ainsi de suite
on va prendre une analogie illustrer les
axiomes ce sont comme des briques de
lego de base qu'on aura le droit
d'utiliser autant de fois qu'on veut est
de combiner entre elles
et quand on combine des briques de base
bah on obtient des structures plus
complexes les théorèmes qu'on peut à
leur tour utiliser et combiné pour
construire des structures de plus en
plus riches
la beauté de la méthode axiomatique
c'est que comme avec les lego en partant
d'un nombre restreint d'axiome on peut
construire tout un tas de théorèmes mais
voyez que ça dépend évidemment du
système d'action qu'on se donne au
départ mon exemple avec les trois
axiomes sur socrate nous a pas emmener
très loin quand on veut faire des
mathématiques
il faut bien choisir son système axiom
et il existe plusieurs possibilités
suivant le domaine dans lequel on veut
travailler
si vous voulez faire de la géométrie
dans le plan vous pouvez utiliser les
axiomes d'euclide de rouler liste ici si
vous voulez plutôt faire de
l'arithmétique des nombres entiers
il est possible d'utiliser les axiomes
10 2 p and o alors voici quelques un
axiome 1 0 est un nombre axiome de tout
nombre possède un suivant actionne 3 0
est le suivant d'aucun nombre axiome 4,6
de nombreux le même suivant ils sont
égaux etc
et puis si vous voulez faire des matches
plus compliqués et ben on se base en
général sur les axiomes de la théorie
des ensembles qu'on appelle les axiomes
zdf c'est le message important ici c'est
que quand on dit qu'un truc est
démontrable s'est jamais démontrable
dans l'absolu c'est toujours
sous-entendu en utilisant un certain
système d'axiome par exemple si je dis
que j'arrive à démontrer qu'il y à une
infinité de nombreux premiers c'est
probablement en utilisant les axiomes de
p and o en tout cas certainement parce
que deux clide et aussi si je prends les
actions de paix à nos et j'envie raoult
2 bat il est vraisemblable que je
n'arrive plus à démontrer qu'il ya une
infinité de nombreux premiers
vous comprenez bien pourquoi vrai et
démontrable c'est pas la même chose
un truc vrai c'est un truc vrai mais un
truc démontrable c'est toujours
sous-entendu en utilisant un certain
système d'axiome et ça dépend du système
axiom qu'on utilise au début du 20e
siècle
le mathématicien david hilbert
traitement
et s'il existait un système d'actions
parfait pour faire des maths un système
parfait ce serait un système avec lequel
absolument tout ce qui est vrai serait
démontrable et inversement
tout ce qui est faux serait réfutable
réfutable ça veut dire qu'on peut
démontrer son contraire un tel système
on appellerait ça un système complet et
voyez qu a priori c'est pas gagné si
j'oublie un axiome je peux réduire
considérablement le champ de ce qui est
démontrable ou réfutable un peu comme si
j'oubliais d'inclure un type de briques
de lego
d'un autre côté contrairement aux lego
avec les systèmes d'axiome il faut faire
un petit peu attention on peut pas
rajouter n'importe comment des axiomes à
tout va parce qu'il ya un danger mortel
qui nous guette qu'on se retrouve en
situation de démontrer un truc et son
contraire je vais reprendre mon exemple
simpliste si je fais pas gaffe et que
j'ajoute deux axiomes à les axiomes 4
socrates est un philosophe et axiom 5
tous les philosophes sont immortels mais
voyez que j'ai un soucis j'ai déjà
montré que socrate était mortel s'était
montée or m mais là en combinant le 4 et
le 5 je tiens nouveau théorème qui dit
que socrate est immortel donc avec mon
système d'axiome j'arrive à démontrer un
truc et son contraire et en maths on
veut surtout pas ça arrivait à démontrer
un truc et son contraire ce serait
l'équivalent d'un cataclysme logique un
système d'axiome qui évite cet écueil
on dit qu'il est cohérent et donc voilà
l'idée de gilberte de trouver un système
d'actions parfait c'était d'avoir un
système d'axiome qui soit à la fois
complet mais aussi bien sûr cohérent
l'espoir de gilberte c'était d'arriver a
prouvé qu'on était en train de bâtir les
mathématiques sur un socle solide et
bien c'est cet espoir que gödel la
torpiller
le premier théorème d'incomplétude de
gödel nous dit la chose suivante à
partir du moment où on peut faire au
moins de l'arithmétique
quel que soit le système d'axiome qu'on
utilise il existera toujours des
affirmations qui ne sont ni démontrable
ni réfutable ces affirmations ont dit
qu'elles sont indécidable et pourtant
ces affirmations sont quand même soit
vrai soit fausse mais on peut pas le
démontrer avec les axiomes et donc
quelle que soit la manière dont on les
choisit snow système d'action seront
toujours nécessairement incomplet et
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça le
théorème d'incomplétude si je reprends
mon analogie de lego ça revient à dire
que quelles que soient les formes et les
couleurs des briques de base que je me
donne
il existera toujours des structures que
je n'arriverai pas à construire mais ça
veut dire quoi une affirmation
arithmétique qui soit vrai mais
indémontrable je vous ai parlé dans une
vidéo précédente de la conjecture de
goldbach
celle qui dit que tout nombreux pères à
partir de 4 peut s'écrire comme somme de
deux nombres premiers
mais on a cherché par ordinateur jusqu'à
un milliard de milliards
et ça marche on n'a jamais trouvé de
contre exemple c'est donc que ça doit
être vrai mais personne n'arrive à le
démontrer eh bien peut-être que c'est
vrai mais indémontrable avec les actions
qu'on utilise peut-être que la
conjecture de goldbach est indécidable
dans notre système d'axiome et ce qui
est fou c'est qu'il n'y a aucun moyen de
rafistoler notre système
quelles que soient les actions qu'on
utilise il existera toujours des
propositions indécidable des sortes de
zones d'ombré et ça ça montre que la
méthode axiomatique elle est
intrinsèquement limités même pour une
chose aussi simple que l'arithmétique
des nombres entiers alors rassurez vous
un des propositions qui soient à coup
sûr indécidable on en croise quand même
pas tous les jours
l'une d'elles je l'avais évoqué dans ma
vidéo sur l'infini c'est l'hypothèse du
continue la question de savoir s'il
existe un infini plus grand que celui
des nombres entiers mais plus petit que
celui des nombres réels et bien
l'hypothèse du continue c'est une
proposition indécidable même avec les
axiaux medef c'est de la théorie des
ensembles
maintenant que vous avez une idée de ce
que raconte ce théorème on va s'attarder
un peu sur sa démonstration la ville
comment c'est possible de démontrer un
truc pareil
évidemment je vais pas vous faire la
démonstration en entier et en détail
même si elle est pas si compliqué que ça
une fois qu'on a pigé la philosophie
générale est justement je voudrais vous
donner un aperçu de cette philosophie
alors considéré l'affirmation suivante
il existe une infinité de nombreux
premiers
cette affirmation c'est une affirmation
arithmétique qui peut
les nombres entiers et elle est soit
vraie soif hausse en l'occurrence lé
vrai maintenant considérer l'affirmation
la proposition il existe une infinité de
nombreux premiers et démontrable cette
affirmation elle est vrai aussi mais
c'est pas une affirmation arithmétique
elles portent pas sur les nombres
entiers eux mêmes mais sur l'existence
d'une démonstration on dit que c'est une
affirmation meta arithmétique
la distinction est vraiment essentiel
quand je dis qu'un truc sur les nombres
est vrai je fais une affirmation
arithmétique mais quand je dis que ce
truc est démontrable je fais une
affirmation meta arithmétique et c'est
là que gödel a trouvé un truc diabolique
quand je dis qu'un truc est démontrable
eh ben ça veut dire que je peux écrire
une suite d'affirmations qui partent des
axiomes et qui les combines pour arriver
jusqu'à monter or m
chacune de ces lignes on pourrait
l'écrire avec des symboles mathématiques
convenu d' avance de manière à
s'affranchir de la langue et à tout
écrire de manière formalisé comme une
suite de formule goodell a proposé
d'associer un nombre à chaque symbole et
de construire avec un nombre qui va
représenter chaque formule de manière
unique
c'est une manière de coder les formules
avec des nombres et grâce à cette astuce
je peux finalement ramené toute ma
démonstration qui était une suite de
formules à une suite de nombres qui
s'enchaînent selon certaines règles
si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez aller
regarder ça un peu plus en détails ça
s'appelle le codage de gödel ça peut
paraître complètement stupide comme idée
parce qu'on part d'une démonstration
avec des formules qui est déjà pas
forcément hyper simple à comprendre et
on ramène ça à une suite de nombres
donc ça obscurci complètement la
démonstration on pige plus rien mais
voilà à quoi ça va servir
prenez une affirmation arithmétique
qu'on va appeler a par exemple il existe
une infinité de nombreux premiers dire
que a est démontrable
c'est la même chose de dire qu'il en
existe une démonstration bon ok ce qui
grâce au codage de gödel et la même
chose que de dire qu'il existe une
certaine suite de nombres qui
s'enchaînent selon certaines règles et
qui codent cette démonstration est
l'existence de cette suite de nombres et
bien ça c'est une affirmation
arithmétique mais ce n'est pas la même
que l'affirmation arithmétique armés on
peut lui associer on va l'appeler c2a et
pourquoi c'est génial parce que d'un
côté on a une affirmation mme et
arithmétique de démontre habilité entre
pas très palpable et qu'on arrive à lui
associer une bonne vieille affirmation
arithmétique classique
on dit parfois que gaudeul
a réussi à refléter la méta arithmétique
dans l'arithmétique
passons maintenant à la deuxième astuce
qui permet de faire la démonstration du
théorème de gödel vous connaissez le
paradoxe du menteur
vous savez l'histoire du menteur qui
vous dit je suis en train de vous mentir
sauf que si vous ment c'est finalement
il est en train de dire la vérité
mais s'il dit la vérité c'est qu'il vous
manque paradoxe eh ben goodell s'est un
peu inspiré de ça on l'a dit grâce au
codage à toute affirmation arithmétique
a on peut associer une affirmation codé
c2a tels que a est démontrable si et
seulement si ces deux à evry et bien par
un procédé astucieux que je vous épargne
godall a montré qu'on pouvait toujours
fabriqué une affirmation arithmétique en
particulier on va l'appeler juger en son
honneur
tel que ces 2 g soit le contraire de g
qu'on appelle parfois non j'ai cette
affirmation g on l'écrit pas
explicitement on sait qu'elles existent
ça nous suffit
et donc pour elle on à g et démontrable
si et seulement si non j'ai est vrai ou
autrement dit g et démontrable si et
seulement si j'ai est fausse alors
prenez une bonne inspiration et examiner
cette phrase deux minutes
vous voyez qu'on a deux cas de figure
soit g est fausse et démontrable soit
al'inverse g est vrai est indémontrable
alors à commencer par le second kg est
vrai est indémontrable et ben voilà on y
est c'est ce dont je vous parle depuis
le début si c'est vrai ça veut dire
qu'on a réussi à construire une
affirmation en particulier qui est à la
fois vrai mais indémontrable et donc le
système d'action qu'on utilise est
nécessairement un complet intuitivement
on pour essayer de sauver les meubles en
disant cette proposition g qui est
indémontrable gk la rajouter à mon
système d'axiome comme ça je suis
tranquille et bien non parce que la
construction de gödel fonctionne quel
que soit le système d'axiome donc on
pourra toujours recommencer ce petit jeu
et construire une nouvelle proposition à
décide à bhl même avec des systèmes
d'action aussi riche qu'on veut il
restera toujours des zones d'ombré tout
ça nous dit que le rêve de gilberte de
trouver un système d'actions parfait et
bien il est sans espoir
alors notez bien ça nous empêche pas de
faire des matins mais parfois on peut se
trouver dans des situations on soit
obligé de passer dans un système
d'actium plus puissants pour pouvoir
démontrer des choses prenons un exemple
un vous connaissez certainement le
théorème de fermat
celui qui dit que dès que n est plus
grand que trois il est impossible de
trouver trois nombres entiers tels que x
puissance n + y puissance n égale z
puissance n
donc ça c'est une affirmation purement
arithmétique 1 donc on aura envie de
penser qu'on doit pouvoir l'a démontré
en utilisant juste les axiomes de
l'arithmétique de p and o eh bien
peut-être que c'est possible mais
aujourd'hui la démonstration existantes
de andrew wiles utilisent des maths bien
plus sophistiqué que la simple
arithmétique et donc se base sur les
actions et dave c'est de la théorie des
ensembles et en fait peut-être que
fermat est indémontrable si on se limite
aux axiomes de p and o mais on ne sait
pas tout à l'heure je vous ai dit que
goodell avait réussi à démontrer qu'on
pouvait toujours construire une
proposition j'ai telles que g soit
démontrable si et seulement si elle est
fausse
alors on a traité le premier cas celui
où j'ai est vrai est indémontrable mais
qu'est ce qu'il en est du deuxième celui
où j'ai est fausse et démontrable et
bien dans ce cas là c'est encore pire
parce que ça veut dire que notre système
d'axiome nous permet de démontrer des
choses fausses et là c'est la
catastrophe
tout ce qu'on a pu construire avec
s'effondre on dit que c'est un système
incohérent en résumé gödel nous dit qu'à
partir du moment où on fait au minimum
de l'arithmétique
quel que soit le système d'action qu'on
utilise il est soit incomplètes soit
incohérent
c'est à dire qu'on a le choix entre la
peste et le choléra
bah non pas le choléra mais disons entre
la peste et le rhume si notre système
d'action mais incomplet c'est le rhume
s'il est incohérent là c'est franchement
la peste alors rassurez vous ainsi les
axiomes qu'on utilise tous les jours
pour faire des maths était incohérent on
pense qu'on s'en serait rendu compte
on aurait déjà réussi à démontrer un
truc et son contraire c'est par exemple
ce qui s'était passé avec les tous
premiers axiome de la théorie des
ensembles dans la théorie des ensembles
naïve telles qu'elles avaient été
formulées au début et qu'on a depuis
abandonné
on a le droit de faire des ensembles de
tout et n'importe quoi et notamment des
ensembles d'ensemble est on autorisé
même qu'un ensemble puissent se contenir
lui même et tout ça avait aboutit à un
paradoxe logique si un ensemble peut se
contenir lui-même
on peut définir l'ensemble des ensembles
qui se contient de même en hockey et
al'inverse on peut parler de l'ensemble
des ensembles qui ne se contiennent pas
eux mêmes cet ensemble on va l'appeler
eux
question est ce que eux se contient
lui-même je vous laisse vous convaincre
que ya un paradoxe logique s'il se
contient lui-même alors il ne se
contient pas lui-même et boum
depuis on a guéri les axiomes de la
théorie des ensembles et le problème
s'est jamais représenté donc on a de
bonnes raisons de penser que s'il y
avait eu une contradiction on l'aurait
trouvée rapidement
n'empêche qu'on aimerait bien pouvoir
être certain de ça quand on voit un
système d'axiome on voudrait être
capable de dire si on est dans la
situation rhume ou peste c'est à dire si
et incomplets ou incohérents en pratique
ce qu'on aimerait surtout être capable
de démontrer c'est qu'il n'est pas
incohérent
c'est à dire qu'il est incomplet mais
c'est quand même moindre mal et bien la
barbe
goodell a à nouveau torpillé cet espoir
goodell a démontré que la cohérence d'un
système d'axiome faisait justement
partie des propositions indécidable de
ce système c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
démontrer qu'un système d'axiome et
cohérent en restant à l'intérieur de ce
système on appelle ça le second théorème
d'incomplétude de gödel est évidemment
essentiel même si on oublie parfois il a
d'ailleurs fait très mal alberte
résumons la situation
le premier théorème d'incomplétude de
gödel nous dit que tout système d'axiome
qu'on utilise pour faire au moins de
l'arithmétique et soit incomplètes soit
incohérent et le deuxième théorème nous
dit que la cohérence ne peut pas être
démontrée en restant à l'intérieur du
système alors en apparence le théorème
de gödel est catastrophique
il nous dit au mieux qu'il existera
toujours des zones d'ombré c'est à dire
des choses qu'ils soient vrais mecs on
n'arrivera jamais à démontrer avec les
axiomes qu'on utilise et au pire que
notre système est incohérent c'est à
dire qu'on est peut-être en train de
démontrer des trucs complètement faux et
qu'un jour tout va s'effondrer alors ça
c'est la théorie mais rassurez-vous en
pratique le théorème de gödel n'est pas
bien grave si vous êtes au lycée allait
pas voir le prof de maths en lui
demandant s'il est certain que l'exode
numéro 17 serait pas par hasard une
proposition indécidable ou bien en
suggérant que le système d'action qu'on
utilisait peut-être incohérent non on
sait fabriquer explicitement des
propositions indécidable elles sont déjà
assez sophistiqué et puis il y en a pas
légions 1
et généralement on s'en sort en
utilisant un système d'axiome plus fort
par exemple en utilisant les axiomes de
lfc au lieu des axiomes de
l'arithmétique de p and o l'intérêt du
théorème de gödel il est surtout
conceptuel un philosophique mais en
pratique il n'empêche pas les
mathématiciens de dormir en faut quand
même dire un truc ce théorème il a été
beaucoup abusé et déformé pour lui faire
dire tout et n'importe quoi les choses
du genre rien n'est certain la
connaissance humaine est à jamais limité
bien les mac ne nous disent rien de
connaissable avec certitude n'en
retenait que le théorème de gödel
s'applique dans un cadre très précis les
systèmes d'axiome et je devrais ajouter
récursif qui contiennent au moins à
l'arithmétique donc ne faites pas dire à
goebbels qui n'a pas dit sur un sujet
comme celui-ci il ya évidemment plus que
jamais plein de choses que j'aurais pu
raconter en plus pour préciser des trucs
un peu floue voire même carrément un peu
faux que j'ai dit par exemple ça un truc
vrai c'est un truc vrai ou bien encore
ça même avec des systèmes d'action aussi
riche qu'on
si ces questions vous intéresse j'en
parle dans le billet qui accompagne la
vidéo et qui vous parle notamment de la
théorie des modèles ou du théorème de
complétude de gödel qu'il a démontré
pendant sa thèse avant de démontrer ce
frm d'incomplétude autre aspect que j'ai
également passé sous silence
on peut avoir sur le théorème de gödel
un regard beaucoup plus algorithmique
plus proche de ce que font les gens qui
font de l'informatique théorique par
exemple j'ai choisi de ne pas prendre
cette présentation les thomas de la
chaîne patience a fait une vidéo très
bien sur le sujet que vous encourager à
les voir merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à liker
à la partager à vous abonner
vous pouvez suivre les actualités de la
chaîne sur facebook et sur twitter et
vous pouvez aussi me soutenir sur tipi
un grand merci à tous les types heures
qu'ils soutiennent
à bientôt
[Musique]